la séance est ouverte
le compte rendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribuée nous
n'avons pas reçu l'observation il y en
a-t-il en séance
je n'envoie point le procès-verbal est
donc adopté sous les réserves d'usage
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues notre ordre du jour appelle
les questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement notre séance est
retransmise en direction Public Sénat et
sur notre site internet chacun sera
attentif au respect des uns et les
autres et au respect du temps de parole
je vais donner immédiatement la parole
au président Pierre Laurent pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste vous avez la parole monsieur
le président
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre non content de mettre le pays
dans la rue et bientôt à l'arrêt sur les
retraites votre gouvernement vient de
provoquer un nouveau vent de colère
contre la suppression de postes et de
classe dans l'éducation nationale par an
élève et enseignants ont découvert en
janvier une carte scolaire actant sans
concertation mille suppressions de poste
en primaire et 500 dans le secondaire et
les mobilisations se multiplient un peu
partout à la rentrée dernière vous
peignez à mettre un enseignant devant
chaque classe allant jusqu'à recruter à
la va-vite fin août sur Job Dating des
enseignants précaires 4 mois plus tard
vous nous dites qu'il y a trop
d'enseignants et de classe en France
pouvez-vous nous expliquer ce tour de
passe-passe
dans de nombreux départements les
établissements auraient et auraient plus
sont les premiers touchés à Paris c'est
une véritable saignée
337 postes et 240 classes supprimées
cela fait suite en plus au scandale de
la fermeture de cette lycées
professionnels parisiens décidez par
Valérie Pécresse avec la valve du
ministère mais le problème n'est pas
limité à la capitale les banlieues comme
les zones rurales sont durement frappées
entendez-vous l'appel des mers ruraux
qui demandent à moratoire immédiat sur
les fermetures de classe et des colles
monsieur le ministre pendant la coïde le
gouvernement nous expliquait que le
temps éducatif devait être protégés
comme la prunelle de nos yeux
aujourd'hui vous jetez tout ça aux
oubliettes l'éducation nationale
redevient une cible prioritaire des
coupes budgétaires
alors les mêmes dogmatismes budgétaires
ont fabriqué les pénuries et les déserts
médicaux dont nous souffrons aujourd'hui
dans tout le pays monsieur le ministre
allez-vous créer les pénuries et les
déserts éducatifs de demain
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse monsieur peuple
merci monsieur le Président de Mesdames
et Messieurs le les sénateurs monsieur
le Président Laurent j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de le dire dans cette
hémicycle nous allons perdre environ 500
000 élèves dans les 5 années à venir et
la situation est plus aiguë encore à
Paris puisque la baisse de la natalité
se combine au déménagement hors de Paris
des familles et notamment des familles
avec des jeunes enfants alors quelle est
la réalité de la situation à Paris
permettez-moi trois données la première
c'est le nombre la diminution du nombre
d'élèves à Paris elle est de moins 20%
ces 10 dernières années et cela va
continuer dans les cinq années à venir
19,8 c'est le nombre d'élèves moyens par
classe à Paris il est de 21,7
au niveau national enfin Paris bénéficie
d'un maillage des écoles qui est le plus
dense de France avec un réseau de
transport sans équivalent sur le
territoire français nos critères pour
assurer la répartition des postes sur le
territoire sont simples équité et
universalité ma responsabilité c'est
bien celle de l'équité territoriale et
celle-ci effectivement amène à faire des
choix des choix pour que le service
public d'éducation soit préservé sur le
territoire français des choix pour que
nos professeurs soient mieux rémunérés
la hausse du budget de l'Éducation
nationale elle est de 6,5% cette année
pour mémoire elle était de 2% en moyenne
annuelle entre 2012 et 2017 alors
monsieur le Président il ne s'agit pas
d'opposer les territoires les uns aux
autres mais nous devons considérer avec
justesse l'ensemble des situations et de
prendre la hauteur de vue pour assurer à
tous les meilleures conditions
d'éducation
Monsieur Laurent quelques secondes
oui il faut pas opposer les territoires
mais c'est exactement ce que vous venez
de faire pour vous la calculette elle
fonctionne toujours dans le même sens
vous utilisez toujours le règlement de
la démocratie vous le connaissez calaos
qu'à la baisse mais jamais à la hausse
contre la question se pose donc vous
devriez revoir vos calculs parce que
dans beaucoup de territoires la colère
va continuer à monter sur ce sujet
donner la parole à notre collègue Xavier
yakovelli pour le groupe du
Rassemblement de démocrates
progressistes et indépendant
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre comme vous le savez les Jeux
Olympiques approchent et les transports
en Île-de-France seront une question
centrale aujourd'hui le réseau est
surchargé par les milliers de
Franciliens qui prennent les transports
véritable galère au quotidien entre
retard suppression ou encore trainé
certains ou même certaines posent même
clairement la question de notre capacité
à accueillir cet événement cette semaine
vous avez visité le chantier Éole ce
grand projet du prolongement du RER E
vers l'ouest parisien et je me félicite
que l'État puisse accompagner la région
Île-de-France sur ces projets mais
aujourd'hui l'État ne peut pas tout
faire et je rappelle que la compétence
transport était avant tout une
compétence de la région car au-delà des
Jeux Olympiques c'est l'ensemble du
financement des transports en
Île-de-France qu'il faudrait repenser
dès 2024 c'est-à-dire demain 600
millions d'euros manqueront à l'appel
pour financer le fonctionnement des
nouvelles lignes actuellement en
chantier le réseau Francilia va donc en
effet doublé d'ici 2030 et on estime à
1,3 milliards les besoins de financement
il y a deux ans la chambre régionale des
comptes tirez déjà la solette d'alarme
sur la gestion inadaptée et
déséquilibrée d'Île-de-France mobilité
l'endettement de cette opérateur après
avoir été multiplié par 7 entre 2013 et
2018 a encore augmenté de 64 % pour la
seule année 2022 face aux difficultés
accumulées en décembre dernier l'État
est à nouveau venu au secours
d'Île-de-France mobilité en abondant son
budget de 200 millions d'euros et malgré
cela malgré cela Île-de-France mobilité
a décidé d'augmenter le prix du Pass
Navigo pour un service qui continue de
se dégrader et notamment dans le RER B
et D
alors il y a quelques semaines chers
collègues mais oui il y a quelques
semaines c'est tenu une conférence sur
le financement des transports
franciliens monsieur le ministre qu'elle
piste ont été retenus pour trouver une
solution de long terme permettant aux
transports francilien d'être à la fois
financé d'accueillir correctement des
millions de visiteurs et permettent aux
Franciliens qui travaillent d'avoir des
transports à l'heure suffisant et de
qualité je vous remercie pour vous
répondre la parole est à monsieur
Clément vaut le ministre délégué chargé
des transports monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur yakovelli vous avez la question
spécifique d'abord des Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques nous avons décidé de
mettre en place au niveau de l'État je
préside cet instant avec Amélie ou dia
Castéra un comité stratégique des
mobilités pour regrouper toutes les 6
semaines tous les acteurs dont la région
Île-de-France bien sûr pour faire
avancer nos chantiers notamment les
grands projets d'infrastructures qui
devront être prêts pour les Jeux
Olympiques et bien bien évidemment
bénéficier aux Franciliens bien au-delà
des Jeux Olympiques c'est lequel
notamment du chantier Eole et je me
félicite que collectivement nous ayons
trouvé un accord de financement sur les
surcos pour assurer son fonctionnement
pour une première branche dès le
printemps prochain ce projet financé
pour moitié par l'État nous avons trouvé
cet accord consensuel c'est dans cet
esprit que je crois que nous devons
avancer globalement sur les transports
franciliens vous avez soulevé un stand
de difficulté de financement je veux
quand même rappeler d'où nous partons je
rappelle que nous avons un contrat de
plan état région qui est en train de se
terminer l'État finance en Île-de-France
40% des besoins c'est un inédit en
France pendant la crise de la covid nous
avons permis de verser 2 milliards
d'euros d'avance remboursables de la
région Île-de-France c'était nécessaire
là aussi il n'y a aucun équivalent en
France et je pense que c'était important
cela mérite d'être rappelé j'ai décidé
le Parlement à voter dans le budget pour
2023 200 millions d'aide exceptionnelles
c'est aussi totalement sans comparaison
en France pour l'île de France pour
l'année 2023 il faut que nous me
trouvions maintenant une méthode et un
accord durable pour le financement les
transports en l'Île-de-France c'est la
raison pour laquelle avec Valérie
Pécresse nous avons qu'au président des
Assises du financement des transports
franciliens je pense que c'était une
bonne initiative des pistes ont été
évoquées au début du mois de à la fin du
mois de janvier pardon et nous sommes
mis d'accord je crois qu'il faut nous en
tenir à cette méthode loin des
polémiques ou des micro-tendus pour
avoir dès le mois d'avril un diagnostic
partagé sur les besoins et les pistes de
financement et avant l'été donc avant le
budget qui sera soumis au Parlement des
pistes de financement précises pour
assurer dans la durée le financement de
l'ex des lignes du Grand Paris Express
qui font là aussi l'objet d'un effort
sans précédent de l'État je crois que
c'est dans cet esprit de responsabilité
qu'on doit ensemble avancer désormais
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Ghislaine pour notre collègue Franck
montoger par delémois pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président chers collègues
madame la Première ministre je dis
dernier sur la proposition du groupe
socialiste l'Assemblée nationale s'est
prononcé par 205 voix pour et une contre
en faveur de la nationalisation d'EDF et
de l'incessibilité de son capital détenu
par l'État EDF ne pourrait donc plus
être démantelé livré au marché à la
découpe et parce que les filets de
sécurité que vous avez mis en place sont
très insuffisants pour sauver les
entreprises souvent artisanales comme
les boulangeries le texte de leur
permettrait à toute d'accéder au tarif
régulé courageusement les députés du
parti gouvernemental ont quitté
l'hémicycle au moment du vote de ce
texte ce qui en dit long d'abord sur
leur respect de la démocratie
parlementaire mais plus profondément
encore madame la Première ministre cette
attitude est le reflet de l'impensé
politique du gouvernement à l'égard de
votre projet industriel pour EDF comme
de vos objectifs concrets de la forme du
marché de l'électricité dans l'intérêt
général des Français et de toutes nos
entreprises madame la Première ministre
si ce texte qui est maintenant sur le
bureau du Sénat nous vous convient pas
quels sont vos propositions alternatives
pour EDF comment entendez-vous répondre
immédiatement aux difficultés de
beaucoup d'entreprises dont l'existence
est en jeu et les dirigeants avec leurs
salariés dans un grand désarroi
pour vous répondre
la parole des communistes de l'économie
des finances et de la souveraineté
industrielle et numérique Monsieur Bruno
Le Maire
monsieur le Président et mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Franck motoge je vais vous dire
le fond de ma conviction sur ce texte
je ne vois pas ce qu'il rapporte
mais je vois très bien ce qu'il coûte 18
milliards d'euros
je pense qu'il rapporte parce que nous
avons engagé la prise de participation
de DF par l'État à hauteur de 100% que
nous détenons au moment où je vous parle
96% des titres donc je ne vois pas à
quoi ça sert de faire un texte de loi
pour nationaliser EDF alors que l'État
va avoir 100% des titres d'ici quelques
semaines et que nous en avons déjà 96%
alors vous me dites c'est le projet
Hercule vous allez vouloir démantel mais
dans quelle langue faudra-t-il dire et
répéter que le projet Hercule est mort
et enterré et que nous voulons préserver
l'unité de DF pourquoi voulez-vous que
nous reprenions les titres de DF et
maîtriser à 100% cette entreprise pour
en faire un grand service public si
c'était pour démanteler derrière
l'entreprise cela n'aurait absolument
aucun sens je veux que les choses soient
claires et entendu quant à ce qu'elle
coûte 18 milliards d'euros moi je veux
bien qu'on est tendre qu'on ne propose
cette proposition de loi l'ensemble des
tarifs réguliers électricité non
seulement très petites entreprises non
seulement petites entreprises mais aussi
au PME monsieur aux entreprises de
taille intermédiaires comme vous le
proposez c'est à dire quasiment tout le
tissu économique français pour 18
milliards d'euros est-ce que vous croyez
sérieusement monsieur le sénateur que
toutes les entreprises françaises ont
besoin que 18 milliards d'euros d'argent
public du contribuable soit mise à
contribution pour les soutenir face à la
crise de l'électricité je pense que
c'est tout simplement un gigantesque
gaspillage d'argent public vous dites
toujours que nous en faisons trop pour
les entreprises et bien là je peux vous
dire que ce serait infiniment trop et
tout simplement de gaspillage d'argent
public nous allons nous allons prendre
le contrôle à 100% d'EDF demandez à EDF
de remettre en état les réacteurs
nucléaires qui doivent l'être s'engager
totalement sur la construction de six
nouveaux EPR maintenir l'unité du groupe
EDF voilà la feuille de route qui était
fixée au nouveau président d'EDF quant à
la réforme du marché européen je vous
rejoins
nous devons cette bataille avec la
première ministre nous la gagnerons pour
que nos compatriotes payent l'énergie
nucléaire au prix de l'électricité du
clair
monsieur
montogeth vous avez pas vraiment répondu
à la question relativement
l'organisation de l'entreprise EDF ça
fait des mois que les ministres en
charge nous berce de parole l'initiantes
et que rien ne se profile comme mesure
intense peu efficace en France et en
Europe ce qui est ici en question c'est
la capacité du président de la
République et de votre gouvernement a
peser sur la réforme du marché de
l'électricité dans l'Union européenne
l'entreprise nationale EDF doit être au
cœur de la reconquête de la souveraineté
économique française et le groupe
socialiste du Sénat soutiendra le texte
de Philippe Brun
la parole
et cette fois-ci pour Madame Ghislaine
Portel pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et sociale européen vous
avez la parole monsieur le Président
Madame la première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à madame la
secrétaire d'État notamment chargée de
la vie associative
le projet de réforme des retraites dans
les discussions ont commencé à
l'Assemblée nationale inquiète aussi les
élus locaux et le monde associatif
parce que cela ne relève pas de votre
délégation je ne vous interrogerai pas
sur l'augmentation de la cotisation de
la Caisse nationale de retraite des
agents des collectivités locales que
vous souhaitez imposer aux employeurs
territoriaux à compter de 2024 et à
laquelle il se pose fermement
en revanche parmi les sujets qui
semblent être des angles de morts de
votre réforme il y a les effets que peut
avoir le recul proposé de l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite sur l'engagement
politique et associatif local
en effet la retraite est souvent
l'occasion pour bon nombre de personnes
de franchir le pas d'une candidature à
l'élection municipale de son village ou
d'être administrateur et bénévole d'une
association culturelle sportive ou
sociale
selon une étude réalisée notamment par
la Carsat des Hauts de France 35% des
retraités engagés dans une association
n'était pas engagée avant leur départ en
retraite du côté de l'engagement
politique à la suite des élections
municipales de 2020 le nombre de maires
de plus de 60 ans 60 ans pardon a
atteint 55%
. en somme être retraités c'est un
dossier un rôle non négligeable dans la
cohésion sociale de notre pays qui plus
est lorsqu'on sait que ce sont les
profils les plus assidus dans leur
mission bénévole et fonction électives
du fait de leur disponibilité
mais nous devons malgré tout considérer
que cette situation est fragile car les
difficultés de renouvellement des
équipes sont déjà perceptibles en raison
de statut de l'élu local et de droit des
bénévoles inadaptés à notre époque ainsi
avez-vous anticipé et évalué les impacts
de votre réforme sur la dynamique de
l'engagement je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Olivier Veyron ministre délégué chargé
du renouveau démocratique qui porte
parole du gouvernement merci Monsieur
Président Madame et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice Guylaine
Portel merci pour votre pour votre
question vous m'interrogez sur la prise
en compte du bénévolat dans la réforme
des retraites notamment et il est vrai
que l'engagement associatif constitue
une des pierres angulaire de la cohésion
de notre société l'engagement bénévole
notamment pour les responsables
d'associations ça prend du temps et de
l'énergie alors oui réfléchissons à la
manière de valoriser cette engagement et
de l'encourager la prise en compte pour
la les cotisations retraite pose
toutefois un certain nombre de questions
la première sur les bénéfices sur les
bénévoles à valoriser puisque la plupart
d'entre eux acquièrent déjà des droits à
retraite au titre de leur activité
principale ensuite sur le financement de
ses droits puisque le financement de
trimestre de retraite peut devenir
rapidement une charge difficilement
assumable pour les associations qui sont
concernées plus généralement il nous
appartient de veiller au caractère
contributif et à libre de notre système
de retraite c'est la raison pour
laquelle les modalités d'acquisition de
droit à la retraite pour les bénévoles
doit faire l'objet effectivement d'une
analyse approfondie pour en assurer la
bonne mise en oeuvre nous espérons que
les débats actuellement à l'Assemblée
nationale permettront d'aborder ce sujet
avec les différents amendements qui sont
déposés à l'article 7 je pense en
particulier un amendement du groupe
Renaissance qui vise à évaluer
l'opportunité d'accorder des droits
supplémentaires à la retraite aux
responsables associatifs par ailleurs
vous n'avez pas posé la question mais
vous avez abordé le sujet du financement
de la réforme par les collectivités
territoriales et effectivement le régime
de retraite des fonctionnaires
hospitaliers territoriaux la CNRACL un
déficit qui est important projeté de
l'ordre de 8 milliards d'euros avant
réforme en 2030 c'est avant tout le
résultat d'une question démographique ce
que vous savez et c'est pourquoi le
projet de réforme des retraites prévoit
que les employeurs contribueront
légèrement davantage leur taux de
cotisation passant de 30,65 à
31,65% l'année suivante c'est une hausse
d'un point ça reste largement faire au
taux de cotisation implicite dans la
fonction publique d'État de l'ordre de
74% mais je vous confirme que l'État
sera aux côtés des collectivités pour
les accompagner et assurer une
compensation madame la Première ministre
a répondu par écrit à David Lisnard le
président de l'AMF pour préciser ce
point et annoncer qu'une concertation
avec les ministres concernés je vous
remercie merci
la parole est maintenant de notre
collègue Daniel broyier pour le groupe
écologiste solidarité territoire
[Applaudissements]
ma question s'adresse à Madame panier
rue Nachet ministre de la transition
énergétique madame la ministre pour le
nucléaire rien n'est donc impossible le
Pr Flamanville est un échec opérationnel
et économique selon la Cour des comptes
mais qu'importe le président engage la
France pour six nouveaux EPR le débat
public sur les EPR 2 est en cours la
concertation sur le mix énergétique n'a
pas encore eu lieu comme disait mon
collègue Daniel salmon ici même mais
qu'importe on vote une loi
d'accélération du nucléaire qui change
le mix énergétique avant d'en débattre
au fond et lundi dernier nouveau fait du
prince les salariés de l'Institut de
radioprotection et de sûreté nucléaire
l'IRSN ont appris le démantèlement de
leur institution pourtant reconnu
internationalement la surprise fut
totale créant sidération et inquiétude
pour ces 1700 salariés l'IRSN n'a jamais
failli dans ses missions au bénéfice de
la sûreté l'organisation dual choisit
avec la distinction entre d'un côté
l'indépendance de l'expertise et de la
recherche via l'IRSN et de l'autre le
contrôle et la décision via l'ASN c'est
avéré efficace et garante de la sûreté
c'est un garde-fou institutionnel
construit après la catastrophe de
Tchernobyl et dont l'utilité a été
prouvé après Fukushima alors que vous
relancez un programme nucléaire
d'ampleur il nous paraît essentiel de ne
pas casser une organisation qui a fait
la preuve de son efficacité pourquoi
voulez-vous démanteler l'IRSN est-ce une
demande de l'exploitant dès lors que les
exigences de sûreté de l'IRSN qui ne
répondent je le rappelle qu'au seul
considération scientifiques lui
apparaissent trop élevé madame la
ministre vous n'avez jamais évoqué cette
hypothèse lors de nos débats récents sur
l'accélération du nucléaire quel
reproche formez-vous à l'encontre de
l'IRSN et de ses agents alors que toutes
les évaluations sont positives ou sont
les impacts d'une telle mesure pourquoi
éloigner la représentation nationale de
ces choix essentiels pour accélérer le
nucléaire vous n'avez pas à affaiblir
les exigences de sûreté
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur de
la recherche madame Retailleau
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur broyer tout à l'heure tout
d'abord je voudrais excuser ma collègue
ministre de la transition énergétique
qui est retenue au Parlement européen
justement pour des fentes le nucléaire
bas carbone donc je prends la parole
moi-même alors vous le savez le
gouvernement mène aujourd'hui une
politique énergétique qui vise à la fois
à sécuriser nos approvisionnements que
énergétique mais aussi à garantir des
prix compétitifs pour le pouvoir d'achat
des Français et aussi tout cela en
participant également à la lutte contre
le dérèglement climatique alors pour
cela effectivement nous devons relever
de grands défis et le nucléaire en est
un outil premièrement vous l'avez dit en
réunissant les conditions de
prolongation du parc nucléaire existant
aussi en se mettant en ordre de bataille
pour maîtriser tous les coups et vous
l'avez dit aussi les délais de
construction des nouveaux EPR de et puis
et je voudrais insister aussi sur la
notion d'accélération et de coordination
de la recherche pour le développement en
particulier des petits réacteurs
modulaires français donc vous le voyez
cette relance du nucléaire c'est
effectivement liée à beaucoup d'enjeux
de souveraineté de compétitivité
d'attractivité à long terme mais aussi
de sûreté nucléaires cette sûreté
nucléaire elle est évidemment
complètement nécessaire pour avoir la
confiance des citoyens dans le nucléaire
et vous l'avez dit en poursuivant la
concertation des acteurs locaux et en
développant l'expertise de la filière en
particulier sur le volet de la recherche
mais aussi des entreprises j'en viens
donc sur le fait que depuis toujours il
y a eu la volonté d'assurer cette
indépendance de la sûreté nucléaire et
de maintenir une recherche d'excellence
dans ce domaine l'IRSN est un
établissement public qui a les deux
volets recherche et sur tes nucléaires
et donc aujourd'hui il s'agit de mieux
de plus articuler cette expertise d'un
côté de sûreté nucléaire de l'URSS avec
celui de la SN et de l'autre le volet de
la recherche avec celui de du CEA sur ce
modèle qui existe dans de nombreuses
autres pays et qui aussi font sa preuve
c'est une étude à regarder aujourd'hui
alors ce type de réorganisation vous
l'avez dit doit être fait avec soin et
c'est pour ça qu'on a demandé aux
dirigeants de l'URSS la SN et du CEA de
nous proposer des scénarios merci
beaucoup
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue Joël guerriot
il y avait
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre le 11 février dernier à 13h
sans le moindre préavis des contrôleurs
aériens à Orly se sont mis en grève les
compagnies aériennes ont été
immédiatement contraintes de réduire
leur programme à un vol sur deux 25
arrivés et 22 départs ont ainsi été
annulé
comment peut-on justifier aujourd'hui
que les contrôleurs aériens ne soient
pas soumis aux mêmes règles du droit de
grève que tout autre profession dans le
domaine aérien de tels blocages causent
de graves préjudice un parcours du
combattant commence pour les usagers
dans une pagaille monstre les passagers
doivent trouver des alternatives des
solutions pour répondre à l'urgence et
aussi pour se faire rembourser leurs
billets il y a un peu plus de 4 ans dans
cette hémicycle je présentais une
proposition de loi visant à rendre
obligatoire la déclaration d'un préavis
de grève des contrôleurs aériens entre
2010 et 2016 12 milliards d'euros
avaient été perdus à cause de ces
blocages la France était à l'origine de
97% des perturbations aériennes au sein
de l'Union européenne
l'impact environnemental doit être aussi
pris en considération les compagnies
étrangères contournent le ciel français
sa représente environ 6 millions de
kilomètres additionnels et autant de
pollution
il convient d'assurer la continuité du
service public en soumettant le droit de
grève des contrôleurs aériens un système
de notification préalable de 48 heures
comme c'est d'ailleurs le cas pour
toutes les autres professions du monde
aérien monsieur le ministre n'est-il pas
tant de faire bouger les lignes afin
d'éviter ce genre de situation que vous
avez vous-même qualifié d'irrespectueuse
pour vous répondre la parole des
communistes délégués chargés des
transports monsieur Clément bonne vous
avez la parole merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur guerriot
vous avez raison et je reprendrai les
termes exactes que j'ai employé lundi
après cette grève surprise elle a été
irrespectueuse bien sûr à l'égard des
usagers elle a été irresponsable j'ai
toujours défendu y compris dans ces
moments de tension le dialogue social le
respect des organisations syndicales en
l'occurrence il s'était agit d'un
contournement des appels qui avait été
portés ou qui n'avaient pas été porté
par certaines organisations syndicales
et de quelques individus qui ont très
gravement pénalisé de manière inattendue
de manière surprise et de manière
irresponsable je le redis les départs de
plusieurs milliers de passagers à
l'aéroport d'Orly dans plusieurs
aéroports français vous le savez le
secteur aérien des règles particulières
il est soumis au service minimum en
effet mais pour être activé le service
minimum nécessite un peu de
prévisibilité et ces traditionnellement
dans notre contrôle aérien en France une
forme de pacte social qui permet que la
prévisibilité soit donnée par les
organisations syndicales à la direction
générale de l'aviation civile pour
activer les aéroports qui sont soumis
dont évidemment les grandes plateformes
parisiennes ce service minimum je note
d'ailleurs que dans les journées de
mobilisation des dernières semaines cela
a fonctionné faut-il repenser un certain
nombre de règles ou de pratique au vu de
ce comportement inattendu et
inacceptable je le crois j'ai dès lundi
demandé à la direction générale de
l'aviation civile de mener une
négociation interne d'abord avec les
organisations syndicales pour regarder
ce qui pouvait être fait pour mieux
prévoir les choses et activer s'il le
faut comme nous le ferons à nouveau pour
demain le service minimum pour préserver
au maximum les vols et les usagers
faut-il regarder d'autres options nous y
sommes ouverts sous l'autorité de la
première ministre nous aurons ces
discussions dans les prochaines semaines
la loi n'a pas prévu même si vous l'avez
rappelé il y a déjà eu un certain nombre
de débats sur ce sujet n'a pas prévu en
complément du service minimum une
obligation de déclaration préalable
comme cela existe dans les transports
terrestres par exemple nous regardons
les choses sans tabou d'abord la
négociation interne parce que je crois
ce dialogue social et que ce pacte a
jusqu'à présent fonctionné et puis nous
regarderons avec le Parlement le cas
échéance l'autorité de la première mise
l'ensemble des pistes complémentaires
dont celle que vous avez évoquée dans
les prochaines semaines et dans les
prochains mois si cela est nécessaire
merci beaucoup
moi je pense qu'il est très important
que le cadre juridique français protège
les passagers et à ce titre je voudrais
rappeler qu'il y a une recommandation
européenne qui est de porter le préavis
syndical à 21 jours et individuel à 72
heures donc nous en sommes loin je pense
que nous avons une marge de progrès pour
éviter ce que nous faisons subir à nos
passagers merci
la parole est au président Roger caroci
pour le groupe les républicains
madame la ministre la France dispose
d'une autorité de régulation des médias
arcoms
sur son site
affirme qu'elle travaille naturellement
avec le Parlement puisque le Parlement
désigne 6 de ces 9 membres mais qu'elle
est totalement indépendante du
gouvernement alors madame la ministre
j'aimerais devant la représentation
nationale que vous nous rappeliez votre
définition personnelle de l'expression
totalement indépendante du gouvernement
pour vous répondre à la parole
la madame la ministre de la Culture
monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le vice-président Carotti vous
êtes un grand spécialiste de
l'audiovisuel nous avons eu plusieurs
réunions à ce sujet
et je pense aussi vous reprenez toutes
mes interviews toutes mes déclarations
publiques depuis mai dernier où j'ai été
nommé ministre vous pourrez voir qu'à
aucun moment
à aucun moment je n'ai commenté une
décision de l'arcom à aucun moment je
n'ai fait d'appréciation sur le travail
de l'arcome autorité bien évidemment
strictement absolument indépendante je
me borne à rappeler le cadre de la loi
les obligations les droits et les
devoirs que la loi de 86 prévoit pour
les chaînes qui ont des fréquences
gratuites les chaînes de la TNT je ne
fais rien d'autre que rappeler le cadre
de la loi est-ce qu'une ministre n'a pas
le droit de rappeler la loi
est-ce qu'une ministre n'a pas le droit
de faire état de décision qui sont
publiques de l'art comme j'en fais juste
état je ne les commente pas j'en fais
état je n'ai pas le droit qu'est-ce qui
vous choque et qu'est-ce qui fait peur
où sont les menaces est-ce que si
rappeler le cadre de la loi fait peur
j'ai envie de poser la question à ceux
qui se sentent menacés qu'est-ce qui
vous fait peur merci
[Applaudissements]
monsieur
le président carochi
je vous rassure
reste ton calme je vous rassure madame
la ministre pas grand chose qui me fait
peur mais je ne bois je ne vous reproche
absolument pas de faire des constats ou
des commentaires sur les chaînes c'est
parfaitement votre droit comme c'est le
mien
et j'en fais peu dommage mais en
revanche quand vous dites madame la
ministre
éventuellement je dis pas que vous
affirmez en 2025
l'art comme pourrait retirer l'agrément
non je suis désolé de vous dire retirez
quand vous dites que l'arcome pourrait
retirer si cela continue l'agrément aux
chaînes en question vous interférez
avec les décisions de l'arcom
vous n'avez pas je suis désolé madame la
ministre vous pouvez commenter autant
que vous voulez tout ce que vous voulez
vous n'avez pas à dire ce que l'arcom
pourrait faire en 2025 parce qu'à partir
de là c'est interférer sur
l'indépendance de la com
et moi Madame les ministres je serai
beaucoup plus intéressé par vous
entendre sur cette fameuse réforme de
l'audiovisuel public que nous attendons
depuis cinq ans je serais beaucoup plus
intéressé de vous entendre sur la
manière dont on va financer
l'audiovisuel public puisque depuis que
vous avez supprimé la redevance
audiovisuelle nous sommes dans le
non-dit et l'intérimaire alors madame la
ministre remplissez pleinement vos
fonctions personne ne vous en empêche et
laissez l'art comme faire son travail
[Applaudissements]
la parole la parole est à notre collègue
Amel gaker pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste vous avez la parole
monsieur
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse aux
ministres de la ville et du logement le
1er février dernier la Fondation Abbé
Pierre publié son 28e rapport sur l'état
du mal logement en France le constat est
accablant 330
000 personnes sans logement sur notre
territoire des milliers d'adultes et
d'enfants refusaient chaque soir par le
115 pour un hébergement d'urgence près
de 4 millions de Français mal logés une
situation indigne dans notre pays où
force est de constater que les fractures
ne cessent de s'aggraver en cause des
évolutions conjoncturelles la crise
sanitaire avait déjà fragilisé les plus
précaires l'inflation les a ensuite
atteint de plein fouet aujourd'hui les
dépenses énergétiques deviennent
insoutenables pour de nombreux ménages
modestes cette situation s'explique
également pour des raisons structurelles
le prix Les prix à l'achat et à la
location n'ont cessé de grimper depuis
30 ans et l'effort public pour le
logement en France n'a cessé de chuter
depuis 2010 on le sait le logement est
le premier sujet de préoccupation des
Français mais il devient également une
source aggravante d'exclusion et
d'inégalités à titre d'exemple la
situation des maires de famille
monoparentales 40% des femmes avec un
enfant vivent dans de mauvaises
conditions de logements contre 20% pour
la moyenne de la population vous allez
probablement me dire monsieur le
ministre que vous n'êtes pas responsable
de l'état du mal logement en France qui
perdure depuis trop d'années mais vous
êtes aujourd'hui responsable du
changement de braquet du tournoi à
prendre pour permettre à tous les
Français de se loger dignement monsieur
le ministre allez-vous enfin relancer la
construction de logements neufs
particulièrement de logements sociaux
allez vous renouer avec l'objectif de
500 000 logements neufs par an je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole
est communiste déléguée en charge de la
ville et du logement Monsieur Olivier
Klein vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice yacker oui vous avez raison le
logement est une priorité pour bien
nombreux de nos concitoyens puisque
c'est une recherche importante et il
concourt au bien-être mais vous avez
aussi raison le gouvernement fait un
effort sans précédent pour lutter contre
le sans-abrisme cette question est très
prise en compte depuis le premier
quinquennat le plan logement d'abord un
qui a été lancé par le Président de la
République dès 2017 a permis à plus de
450 000 personnes de sortir de la rue et
avoir un toit mais dans le même temps la
situation sociale économique la
situation migratoire fait qu'il y a
toujours de nombreuses personnes dans
l'hébergement d'urgence et hier soir
encore c'est 200000 places d'hébergement
d'urgence qui était ouverte dans ce pays
et là encore c'est un chiffre qui
n'avait jamais été atteint en 2017 on
avait 140000 places d'hébergement
d'urgence vous le savez une partie
importante des personnes qui sont dans
l'hébergement d'urgence sont des
personnes qui ne sont pas aujourd'hui
éligibles au logement social la
situation de l'hébergement d'urgence
n'est pas liée à une reprise des
expulsions bien au contraire notre
effort quotidien et celui de refuser les
expulsions locatives les prévenir et là
aussi c'était un des axes forts du
premier plan logement d'abord le
deuxième plan logement d'abord que le
gouvernement avec la première ministre
va lancer dans les jours qui viennent
aura un objectif de faire au moins aussi
bien que ces 450 000 personnes mises à
l'abri notamment les femmes sur
lesquelles il y a un travail spécifique
les femmes victimes de violence il y a
10 000 places d'hébergement d'urgence
ouvert pour les femmes victimes de
violence et la première ministre a
annoncé mille places de plus pardon sur
2023 et sur le logement vous le savez le
président de la République est la
première ministre ont décidé de mettre
en place un Conseil national de leur ado
fondation spécifique sur le logement
nous travaillons avec l'ensemble des
acteurs du logement pour construire plus
là on a le plus de besoin et je vous
invite puisque vous êtes tous des élus
locaux apportés avec moi le bâton de
pèlerin pour que les élus et envie de
construire plus là où on a le plus le
besoin merci
Madame geucaire quelques secondes
et bien je ne suis pas rassurée nous
savons ce qu'il y a à faire donc c'est
le moment de passer aux actes
véritablement et juste le logement ce
n'est pas qu'une question technique
c'est une question d'homme et d'humain
il s'agit de la place de chacun dans la
société ça c'est important de le
rappeler merci
la parole
est à notre collègue Jérôme Bacher pour
le groupe les républicain
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues la France a cette avantage
d'être champion champion d'Europe dans
les déficits jumeaux les déficits du mot
c'est à la fois le déficit budgétaire et
le déficit commercial et là pour que la
gemilité soit complète le déficit
budgétaire et le déficit commercial sont
équivalents 160 milliards à peu près
pour chacun je vous félicite pour cet
effort
simplement
plusieurs économistes commencent à
s'inquiéter de la faire et ils ont
raison
Rex et code par exemple nous dit entre
2019 et 2022 la France a perdu des parts
de marché et c'est un dégradé son solde
extérieur dans quasiment tous les
secteurs industriels entre 2019 et 2022
la France perdue terrain par rapport aux
autres grands pays de la zone euro entre
2019 et 2022 la perte des parts de
marché touche quasiment tous les
secteurs des biens à l'exportation
compte tenu de cette constat que
comptez-vous faire pour changer de
direction
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre délégué chargé du Commerce
extérieur de l'attractivité du Français
de l'étranger monsieur belge
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur
d'abord oui vous avez raison le déficit
de la balance des biens à doubler
l'année dernière ce doublement est dû
quasi exclusivement à la facture
énergétique si quasi exclusivement à la
facture énergétique c'est tout à fait le
cas puisque vous le savez le parc
nucléaire a été presque à l'arrêt qui a
du fait des deux années de maintenance
que nous avons dû rattraper du fait de
la pandémie et les prix des énergies
notamment le pétrole et le gaz ont plus
que doublé sur les marchés ce déficit
conjoncturel va s'effacer naturellement
il n'empêche qu'il y a un déficit
structurel j'y reviendrai mais si la
balance des biens a effectivement un
déficit record la balance des services
elle a un excédent record plus de 50
milliards d'euros et la balance des
revenus également un excédent au corps à
plus de 31 milliards d'euros or le
déficit commercial ce n'est pas que la
balance des biens c'est également la
balance des services et la balance des
revenus donc les chiffres sont
évidemment bien moindre que ce que vous
annoncez sur le déficit commercial ils
sont de l'ordre de 50 milliards d'euros
comment comptons-nous agir pour pour
réduire le déficit de la balance des
biens et bien il y a deux voies première
évidemment c'est la réindustrialisation
du pays qui a depuis deux ans nous avons
désormais plus d'usine qui ouvre que
l'usine qui ferme ce sont des cas très
concrets et semi-conducteurs accrol
c'est le paracétamol dans l'Isère c'est
le lithium également dans le Bas-Rhin et
dans l'Allier il y a évidemment il faut
du temps pour réimplanter les usines
mais en tout cas elle a
réindustrialisation est en cours et la
deuxième chose c'est de porter nos PME à
l'exportation nous avons certes de bons
résultats puisque nous avons désormais
000 entreprises qui sont à l'export
c'est 20 000 de plus qu'il y a quelques
années mais il faut encore davantage
porter nos entreprises à l'export c'est
le travail de la team France Export et
des mesures que ce gouvernement prendra
dans les prochains mois merci
le président monsieur le ministre moi
j'ai juste un plombier vos chiffres la
dégradation c'est 60% pour l'énergie et
40 % le reste donc c'est
vos chiffres je n'y peux rien CCA qui
est sorti donc une fois que quand on a
dit ça qu'est-ce que vous avez fait
depuis de nombreuses années parce que
moi ça fait des années qu'on nous entend
dire que vous avez réindustrialisé et
bien nous c'est là vous faisons des
propositions pas plus tard que ce matin
il y a une très bonne PPL trans
partisane mener notamment par mon
collègue Laurent Duplomb qui vous
propose des choses claires c'est pour
favoriser la compétitivité de la ferme
France et bien il faut dénormer arrêter
de mettre de la norme partout sur les
entreprises et la changer tout le temps
par idéologie c'est ce que vous venez de
faire pendant de nombreuses années sur
le nucléaire qui nous a valu
effectivement ce déficit dont vous
parlez il faut arrêter par idéologie de
normer aussi sans arrêt notre
agriculture un coup les néocodynoïdes un
coup non il faut essayer d'avoir de la
constance il faut aussi détaxer et avoir
une politique fiscale
[Musique]
la parole est à notre collègue s'habille
vanegue pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicains vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président ma
question s'adresse à madame la Première
ministre la mobilisation de samedi
dernier contre votre injuste et inutile
réforme des retraites fut une grande
réussite elle a permis à de nombreux
Français de dire pacifiquement
sereinement et avec détermination leur
opposition résolue cette mobilisation a
d'ailleurs été très forte dans les
villes moyennes comme par exemple lance
Boulogne Boulogne ou
saint-paul-sur-ternoise dans le
Pas-de-Calais et quand on dans les dans
les cortèges auprès de population dont
c'est parfois la première mobilisation
on parle de du prix madame la Première
ministre avec comme illustration la
promesse que vous avez faite pendant des
semaines bien que vous vous en défendiez
aujourd'hui d'un minimum de pension de
retraite à 1200 euros les Français ont
compris votre opération d'illusionniste
il n'y aura pas de pension à 1200 euros
sauf pour une très faible minorité de
personnes du prix également sur la
situation des femmes qui sont les
principales victimes de votre réforme
tout comme les catégories populaires
ayant commencé à travailler tôt votre
gouvernement est décidément toujours
doux avec les puissants et dur avec les
plus fragiles le président de la
République le Gouvernement est sa
majorité de circonstances sont
élastiques totalement sourds au
mouvement social sans précédent qui
traversent notre pays face au syndicat
le gouvernement agité le spectre des
blocages à la veille des vacances pour
tenter de retourner l'opinion mais ces
balais bien le président de la
République le Gouvernement et sa
majorité qui bloquent le pays quel
serait les conséquences si votre néfaste
projet suivait son cours sans tenir
compte de son rejet très majoritaire
dans le pays et quand allez-vous enfin
prendre la seule et unique décision
susceptible d'apaiser le pays le retrait
de votre projet de réforme et
l'ouverture de véritables négociations
avec les partenaires sociaux merci
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministres délégués en short du renouveau
démocratique Monsieur Olivier Véran
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice merci pour votre question à
ces général finalement sur la réforme
des retraites par laquelle on s'en
pointe la contestation légitime de votre
camp face à une réforme qui vise à
équilibrer dans la durée un système par
répartition en demandant c'est vrai un
effort aux français via une augmentation
progressive de la durée de travail tout
au long de la carrière madame la
sénatrice
on peut dire ce qu'on veut de la réforme
vous êtes libre de le faire et vous
l'avez fait la triste il y a des mesures
de justice et de progrès dans cette
réforme comme il y en a eu comme il n'y
en avait pas eu dans les réformes des
retraites précédentes parmi lesquels
cette mesure sur le minimum retraite qui
va permettre à 1,8 millions de retraités
actuelles d'avoir une majoration de leur
pension de retraite souvent des petites
retraites nous pourrions nous en réjouir
et qui permettra après de 200 000
nouveaux retraités chaque année de
partir aussi avec un peu plus d'argent
ça sera 35 ans 60 70 ou 100 euros par
mois de plus en fonction de la durée de
cotisation et en fonction du niveau de
revenus tout au long de la carrière ce
que la première ministre avait déjà
annoncé lors de sa conférence de presse
inaugurale un massénatrice hier
l'Assemblée nationale légitime
évidemment dans son exercice a décidé de
rejeter à la majorité l'article 2 du
projet de loi c'est un article qui
disait à mettre en place et qui vise à
mettre en place un index senior vous
aurez en débattre prochainement au Sénat
c'est un article qui vise à faire
régresser les inégalités et les us et
les injustices qui voient de seniors
quittez leur emploi
contraint et forcé par leurs employeurs
parce qu'ils sont justement Seigneur
alors qu'ils ont énormément apporté à
l'entreprise à notre pays non mais c'est
le riche je vous dis ça parce que
pendant des semaines on a entendu des
rangs de vos collègues des rangs de la
nups à l'Assemblée nationale nous dire
qu'il fallait en faire davantage pour
l'emploi des seniors et le moment venu
au moment de voter pour un dispositif
qui peut-être n'est pas parfait à leurs
yeux mais qui améliore considérablement
l'emploi des signaux dans notre pays ont
décidé de s'y opposer j'espère madame la
sédatrice que vous aurez l'occasion
bientôt de voter en faveur de cette
mesure pour revaloriser les petites
retraites pour les Français et que vous
serez appuyer cette fois-ci sur le
bouton favorable je vous remercie
au-delà de la posture et des éléments de
langage que vous nous servez et que vous
nous resservez il y a les chiffres il y
a les faits et vous les connaissez
parfaitement le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicains se restera
très mobilisé contre cette réforme avec
responsabilité et dans le respect du
débat mesdames et messieurs les
ministres écoutez les Français et
écouter les élus
la parole est à notre collègue Jean
Raymond Hugonnet pour le groupe des
République
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires et elle a trait à la
remise en cause des chantiers de
renaturation des cours d'eau le décret
du 30 juin 2020 est très largement
simplifié les procédures préalables à
l'engagement de ce type de travaux en
soumettant ceci non plus à autorisation
mais à déclaration cela a permis
notamment au syndicat mixtes chargés
d'exercer la compétence gemapi de mettre
en oeuvre de nombreux chantiers de
renaturation des cours d'eau en
redonnant un fonctionnement naturel au
cours d'eau en restaurant des
continuités écologiques en améliorant la
richesse et la variété des espèces et
des habitats en renforçant la capacité
de rétention des crues et la réduction
des inondations or un arrêt du Conseil
d'État du 31 octobre 2022 a annulé
l'article du décret du 30 juin 2020 qui
simplifiait grandement les procédures
préalables aux travaux de renaturation
aujourd'hui les présidents de syndicats
mixtes demandent non pas le
rétablissement
identique du texte invalidé par le
Conseil d'État mais il souhaite que les
opérations de renaturation n'aggravant
pas le risque d'inondation n'impactant
pas les moulins ne représentant pas de
danger pour la sécurité publique et
n'ayant aucune incidence dans le domaine
de la production d'énergie il souhaite
tout simplement que ces opérations
demeurent soumises au régime de la
déclaration j'ajoute qu'il est essentiel
pour les collectivités de pouvoir
bénéficier des financements favorables
mis en place par les agences de l'eau
pour des projets très largement
publicités pardon par les élus les
populations et des associations de
défense de l'environnement en l'état le
maintien d'un tel arrêt et la
suppression du système déclaratif fera
de 2023 une année blanche en matière de
travaux de renaturation alors même que
leur financement est assuré et que de
nombreuses entreprises de travaux
publics attendent le lancement de ces
opérations alors Monsieur le Ministre
qu'entendez-vous faire pour que le bon
sens l'emporte
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de la transition écologique de
la cohésion des territoires monsieur
Béchu merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Hugonnet
je vais faire très exactement ce que
vous me suggérez le gouvernement va
prendre un nouveau décret
qui finalement
est l'énumération de ce que vous venez
de dire qui tient compte des quelques
angles morts que le Conseil d'État
pointe comme étant un risque après son
arrêt d'annulation qui a été obtenu à
l'issue d'une attaque par l'association
des Amis des moulins pour que nous
gardions un système simplifié
d'autorisation pour ces travaux les 8
présidents de syndicat mix de votre
département viennent de m'écrire votre
question arrive j'allais dire au moment
où je prends connaissance de leur
courrier les consignes ont été passées
mi mars pas dans trois mois le Conseil
national de l'eau sera saisi de cette
nouvelle rédaction qui est en cours qui
tient compte des remarques du Conseil
d'État mais qui tient compte du bon sens
que vous êtes en train de décrire on
sait que les élus en particulier ceux
qui ont la responsabilité de gemapi
c'est pas qu'ils veulent pas ils sont
convaincus qu'il faut faire il y a des
financements qui existent et on se
retrouve avec des procédures qui ont
s'ajoutant aux procédures finissent par
compliquer la vie de tout le monde quand
il y a des solutions de bon sens
c'était l'objet de ce décret du 30 juin
2020 tout l'enjeu c'est de conserver
cette philosophie de faire en fonction
de ce qui nous remonte du terrain dans
un contexte et c'est là-dessus que je
veux terminer ou nous avons un enjeu de
renaturation parce que l'état global de
nos milieux aquatiques n'est pas bon et
au moment où la Commission européenne
prépare un texte sur la restauration des
milieux aquatiques de manière générale
notre pays en ayant trouvé une solution
doit faire en sorte de la mettre en
oeuvre en conservant cette philosophie
donc vous serez entendu et dans quelques
jours les présidents des syndicats
mixtes qui gèrent cette compétence
auront la satisfaction de voir que dans
la continuité de votre question c'est
exactement ce que nous allons faire
si José monsieur le ministre je dirais
que je bois vos paroles un lendemain de
Saint-Valentin merci d'écouter le Sénat
merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Philippe
Folliot pour le groupe de l'Union
européenne
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse au ministre des Armées il y a
10 jours j'étais au cœur du Dombas et eu
le privilège d'avoir un contact direct
avec des combats des combattants
Ukrainiens revenant du front ou plutôt
des tranchées
c'est Verdun au 21e siècle là-bas froid
bouh puanteur rat tir d'artillerie
continue et ses vagues répétées de chair
à canon russe qu'il faut sans cesse
contenir puis repousser tel est leur
enfer quotidienne et leur seul
préoccupation est de survivre pour cela
ils ont plus que jamais et urgemment
besoin de nous de notre technologie de
nos armes dont le canon César que nous
avons vu en action et qu'il loue pour
son allonge sa précision et sa mobilité
monsieur le ministre allons-nous enfin
accélérer la tendance de livraison des
obus et des pièces détachées qui leur
font si terriblement défaut ainsi que
les 12 Césars supplémentaires prévus
allons-nous livrer les blender légers
promis et si oui quand et combien
allons-nous leur accorder de nouveaux
radars et systèmes de défense elle est
rue ou crotale si utile pour la
protection des infrastructures et des
populations civiles quel est votre
position sur l'impérielle fourniture
d'avions de combat
pour vous répondre
la parole de la secrétaire d'État chargé
aussi un combattant de la mémoire madame
mirales merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Sénateur folio tout d'abord
je voudrais excuser le ministre des
armées qui est retenu à Bruxelles dans
le cadre d'une réunion ministérielle de
l'OTAN monsieur le sénateur je connais
votre engagement sur ces sujets et je
vous suis reconnaissante de les porter
devant nous aujourd'hui dans le cadre du
soutien que la France octroie l'Ukraine
ou nous examinons trois critères
fondamentaux à chaque fois que nous
procédons à une session d'armes à
l'Ukraine un la réponse aux priorités
des demandes des Ukrainiens dans une
logique défensive et dans la maîtrise du
risque d'escalade de la préservation de
notre modèle de sécurité et de défense
trois l'efficacité opérationnelle rapide
des capacités fournies avec des
équipements fonctionnels une formation
adaptée des munitions et le MCO nous
répondons rapidement aux priorités des
demandes ukrainiennes sur les blender de
combat l'artillerie et la défense
solaire les canons César sont une
réponse adaptée 18 canons sont déjà
livrés seront complétés rapidement par
les nouveaux canons français et danois
la France a par ailleurs donné des lr.u
avec des lots de requête de même pour la
défense solaire nous avons déjà livré
des missiles Mistral et des batteries
crâtales nous poursuivrons l'aide à la
protection du territoire
ukrainien en livrant au printemps avec
les Italiens une batterie santé monsieur
le sénateur nous poursuivons la
formation d'unités blindée avec par
exemple des charges légers à mx-10rc qui
iront bien et bientôt en Ukraine par
ailleurs nous avons créé avec le
Parlement un fond spécial de soutien de
200 millions d'euros qui ont déjà été
bien utilisés il permet à l'Ukraine
d'utiliser du matériel directement
auprès des industriels français par
exemple il va permettre la fourniture de
12 Césars supplémentaires et d'un radar
gm200 ils viennent compléter le soutien
que nous portons à travers la facilité
européenne pour la paix nous avons
collectivement engagé plus de 3,5
milliards d'euros nous ne nous
interdisons rien et d'autres sessions
pourraient être engagées et envisager
dans les temps qui viennent
monsieur folio
[Applaudissements]
madame la ministre je regrette que vous
l'ayez pu répondre aux questions très
précises que j'avais posées je dis
simplement qu'il y a une situation qui
est une situation d'urgence sur place et
que nous devons aider l'Ukraine
fortement et maintenant je crois que
c'est un élément et un enjeu essentiel
nous devons et la France doit à l'instar
d'autres pays être en première ligne en
la matière et ceci est très important je
crois que c'est notre devoir mais plus
encore de les aider maintenant et comme
il le faut c'est notre honneur
merci
la parole est à notre collègue Stéphane
sotarel pour le groupe
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la
préparation de la rentrée scolaire
suscite incompréhension et colère dans
nos territoires ruraux nous vous avons
déjà interrogé et nous avons bien
compris que votre matière favorite était
les mathématiques la référence aux ratio
plutôt que les humanités le département
du Cantal n'échappe pas à cette règle
jugnac sans sac 5 centaines morts
inconstances
mené Valette Saint-Martin valmeroux et
de les ternes murain Saint-Flour sur les
victimes de l’année avec cette même
logique inacceptable beaucoup d'autres
termes murain Saint-Flour sur les
victimes de l’année avec cette même
logique inacceptable beaucoup d'autres
suivront
cette année nous sommes en plus victime
d'un marché de dupes qui consiste à
accroître les moyens de votre ministère
vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le ministre
de 6,5% malgré la baisse des effectifs
et de constater les réductions de moyens
sur nos territoires tout cela sans
concertation sans délai de prévenance
avec une méthodologie datant de la
aux élus de s'organiser à ignorant les
initiatives prises sur les territoires
les investissements réalisés
tiens bien qu'on augmente les vôtres ne
le faites pas au détriment des élèves et
des effectifs présents devant élèves
pour le Cantal par exemple c'est
seulement 670 enseignants du 1er degré
sur 780 qui sont devant élève soit un
ratio de
administratif monsieur le ministre
pensez-vous améliorer ce ratio en
remettant des enseignants devant nos
élèves des classes rurales pour ne pas
envoyer un signal mortifère à nos
petites écoles qui sont la vie de nos
communes je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la part le tourisme
de l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse
j'ai pas fait de
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur sautarell la France est
confrontée un problème de natalité qui
n'épargne pas malheureusement votre
département cette situation nous amène
en effet à procéder à des ajustements
dans la carte scolaire selon deux
principes un principe d'équité
territorial et de fait nous accompagnons
les territoires qui gagnent des élèves
en créant des postes de façon
substantielle et deuxièmement un
principe d'universalité de l'école
puisque nous devons avoir une attention
particulière c'est vrai au territoire
ruraux nous sommes dans une phase de la
première phase d'élaboration de la carte
scolaire et cette phase va aboutir à une
autre étape en juin et enfin au mois
d'août au niveau national le nombre
d'élèves par classe et de 21,7 dans
votre département monsieur le sénateur
c'est 17 élèves par classe ce qui est
tout à fait raisonnable nous tenons nos
engagements par l'engagement du
président de la République de ne fermer
aucune école en milieu rurale sans
l'accord du maire et également c'est
l'objet de l'augmentation du budget de
l'Éducation nationale que vous avez
mentionné en augmentant la rémunération
des professeurs pour pouvoir pour
pouvoir pardon les postes mis au
concours il faut mieux payer les
professeurs et c'est ce que nous allons
faire dès la rentrée
merci monsieur le Président le ministre
je crains que vous n'ayez pas tout à
fait répondu à ma question et les ratios
je les connais et je ferai pas l'affront
de vous rappeler en plus l'engagement du
président de la République était de ne
plus supprimer de ne plus fermer de
classe et non pas d'école sans la vie du
maire mais surtout je voudrais mettre
une touche d'humour à ce débat un humour
absurde pour montrer l'absurdité de la
situation que nous vivons chaque jour je
vous invite à lire un texte illustratif
intitulé rationalisation de l'orchestre
j'insiste vraiment lisez-le cela permet
de ramener un orchestre symphonique de
82 à huit musiciens je suis sûr que cela
vous intéressera
la parole est à notre collègue Isabelle
briquet pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre la préparation de la carte
scolaire 2023 2024 se traduit par des
suppressions importantes de postes
particulièrement dans le premier degré
comme ça a été relevé tout à l'heure
dans de nombreux départements la rentrée
sera donc une fois de plus compliqué en
Haute Vienne par exemple de nombreuses
fermetures de classe et suppressions de
postes sont prévues alors même que le
taux d'encadrement est inférieur à la
moyenne nationale la baisse du nombre
d'élèves accueillis ne saurait tout
justifier les laboration de la carte
scolaire ne peut être dictée par de
simples considérations comptables
monsieur le ministre l'école publique
étant bien mauvais état le constat est
cruel mais hélas sans appel dans tous
les territoires ruraux comme urbain en
région comme à Paris dans le primaire
comme dans le secondaire des classes
sans enseignant pendant plusieurs jours
transformés en garderie des brigades de
remplacement dans les effectifs sont
affectés à d'autres missions des enfants
en situation de handicap accueillies
sans moyens supplémentaires c'est-à-dire
sans véritable possibilité d'inclusion
un tel état des lieux justifierait à lui
seul un moratoire sur la fermeture de
classe au-delà de ce moratoire se pose
la question des moyens que nous voulons
donner à l'école publique pour assurer
l'avenir de nos enfants aussi Monsieur
le Ministre comptez-vous sortir de la
logique comptable afin de doter
l'éducation nationale des moyens
indispensables aux besoins des enfants
des enseignants et des territoires je
vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole Leto ministre de l'éducation
nationale
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice briquet je ne reviendrai pas
sur la question démographique sauf pour
noter que dans votre département la
baisse des lèvres sera de 400 400 élèves
à la rentrée je vous rappelle en outre
que la préparation des mesures de
rentrée est un travail qui commence très
en amont et que ce travail comporte
plusieurs la base d'échanges et de
dialogue avant que des décisions
définitives soient prises au mois de
juin et au mois d'août et les décisions
définitives ne sont pas encore prises
avec les dazaines les recteurs les
inspecteurs d'académie nous sommes
encore dans cette phase de dialogue et
d'échanges nous fermons des classes
c'est vrai nous en ouvrant aussi
beaucoup je suis convaincu comme vous
que l'école est un facteur de
dynamisation des territoires et ce
travail doit être mené je vous l'accorde
entre les élus locaux et l'éducation
nationale dans 10 académies aujourd'hui
nous avons créé les territoires
éducatifs ruraux qui permettent d'unir
les forces de l'éducation nationale et
les collectivités c'est un programme
intéressant parce qu'il permet de
construire des projets qui renforcent
l'attractivité des territoires et je
souhaite justement étendre à tous les
territoires ruraux ces programmes qui
montrent déjà leur efficacité enfin
madame la sénatrice je me permets de
vous remarqué à propos des moyens de
l'école que l'augmentation de 6,5% soit
3,7 milliards d'euros c'est une
augmentation conséquente qui va nous
permettre de mieux payer les professeurs
par conséquent de pourvoir les postes
que nous mettons au concours c'est
exactement ce que vous vous n'avez pas
fait entre 2012 et 2017
monsieur le ministre la fin de votre
réponse est un peu facile mais l'effet
sont là promouvoir l'égalité des chances
lutter contre les fractures
territoriales émanciper et formée de
futurs citoyens quels sont les missions
de notre système éducatif monsieur le
ministre notre école va mal la méthode
doit changer vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure tout est question de choix et ce
n'est pas en supprimant des postes que
notre école publique ira mieux
la parole est à notre collègue Fabien
Genet pour le gros plaie républicains
le président
ma question s'adresse au ministre de la
Santé monsieur le ministre naître ou ne
plus naître à hautain tel est désormais
la question question qui angoisse les
62000 habitants du Morvan entre
Saône-et-Loire Nièvre et Côte-d'Or Suite
à votre annonce de la fermeture de la
maternité d'Autun cette fermeture
provoque un vent de colère et de révolte
chez les équipes de soignants au combien
dévoués mais aussi chez les élus locaux
et la population devant ce qui est vécu
comme un nouveau déménagement du
territoire cette fermeture suscite
l'inquiétude des femmes enceintes
désormais contraintes de parcourir plus
d'une heure voire 1h30 de route pour se
rapprocher d'une maternité alors même
qu'une étude réalisée dans notre région
montrait combien l'augmentation de cette
distance retentit sur la santé
périnatale cette fermeture locale doit
préoccuper au niveau national car
monsieur le ministre vous avez commencé
par la justifier ainsi nous n'arrivons
plus à trouver des professionnels pour
assurer la sécurité est-ce donc déjà
votre seul politique après avoir fermé
une maternité sur trois en 20 ans votre
ministère va-t-il amplifier cette
concentration et fermer toutes les
maternités de niveau 1 du pays et puis
face au tollé provoqué par votre annonce
vous avez renié le mot de fermeture dans
un tweet qui disait inexact les
accouchements sont suspendus aujourd'hui
pour manque de personnel finalement
monsieur le ministre de la Santé est-ce
là votre seul ambition face aux pénuries
médicales que de demander aux femmes de
suspendre les accouchements et aux
malades de suspendre leur maladie
pour vous répondre la parole du
communisme de la santé Monsieur François
Brown
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
Jeunet merci de me donner l'occasion de
parler de ce dossier dans le fond et
j'en suis sûr en dehors de toute
polémique
quelle est la situation actuelle les
accouchements sont suspendus à la
maternité d'otin depuis mi-décembre par
faute de personnel médical j'imagine que
comme moi vous refusez de mettre en
danger la santé des femmes par turiante
et des enfants parce qu'elle n'aurait
pas de personnel compétent pour les
prendre en charge alors des décisions
nombreuses ont été prises la première
j'ai décidé de repousser la date de la
commission qui devait dans quelques
jours décider de l'avenir du site pour
que nous prenions un peu plus de temps
pour construire des solutions pour
répondre aux besoins de santé de la
population il est hors de question bien
entendu que les femmes du Morvan n'est
pas de solutions satisfaisante au moment
de leur grossesse
pendant ce temps nous allons continuer à
travailler avec les élus avec les
professionnels avec les représentants
des patients et des patients plusieurs
pistes se dessinent déjà
particulièrement sérieuses la première
met en place sur hautain une ligne
d'intervention supplémentaire avec une
ambulance dédiée et une sage-femme en
complément du SMUR pour la prise en
charge éventuelle d'accouchement qui se
ferait en extra hospitalier ensuite nous
mettons en place un service de
périmaternité à hautain c'est à dire la
prise en charge des femmes jusqu'à
l'accouchement et tout de suite après
l'accouchement avec une antenne
d'ailleurs à Château-Chinon pour mieux
couvrir l'ensemble du Morvan de la même
façon mise en place d'un système
d'hébergement des femmes juste avant
l'accouchement sur notre principe
d'hôtel hospitaliers au plus près du
plateau technique d'accouchement et
enfin la mise en place de consultations
de pédiatrie sur le site en concertation
et en complémentarité avec le CHU de
Dijon et château
Chalon-sur-Saône pardon donc voilà les
solutions que nous travaillons j'aurai
l'occasion de venir sur place pour
présenter les solutions que nous aurons
définies ensemble bien entendu nous
mettrons le financement adéquat pour les
développer je suis de très près ce sujet
car il est emblématique de la
construction d'une réponse à l'échelle
du territoire et non plus simplement de
façon focalisée je vous remercie
monsieur Jeunet
merci Monsieur le Ministre j'entends
votre
proposer effectivement la transformation
de la maternité en centre périnatal de
proximité comme un une très grande
nouveauté alors même que je crois que
les décrets de 1998 il y a 25 ans
prévoyait déjà cette solution et que
dans notre région ça a été tenté à
Cosne-sur-Loire et vous savez que ce
centre a dû fermer faute de personnel je
crois que les acteurs locaux attendent
des garanties réelles pour que votre
beau concept de maternité territoriale
ne soit pas seulement un slogan pour
masquer la réalité celle d'un territoire
sans maternité
merci
la parole est notre collègue Olivier
sigoletti pour le groupe l'Union santé
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
monsieur le ministre le 1er juillet 2007
la France ouvrait son marché de
l'électricité et du gaz à la concurrence
pour les particuliers faisant naître par
la même occasion des promesses sur une
baisse des prix sur un système plus
performant et plus lisible pour les
consommateurs 16 ans après je crois
pouvoir dire au nom de millions de
Français que le poids de l'énergie sur
le budget des ménages est aujourd'hui
extrêmement préoccupant sans surprise
différentes études montrent que le prix
d'électricité a progressé de 50% en
disant et ce n'est malheureusement pas
terminé même constat alarmant pour le
gaz au final comme souvent c'est le
consommateur qui paie les frais de la
situation actuelle dont les causes sont
multiples guerre en Ukraine marché
européen de l'énergie en difficulté et
stratégie énergétiques des différents
gouvernements souvent incohérentes
pourtant
d'ici le 30 juin 2023 les tarifs
réglementés du gaz sont vous et à
disparaître obligeant des millions de
ménages à renégocier leur contrats avec
des tarifs qui vont bondir alors que la
reprise économique s'amorce en Chine et
que ce pays va fortement augmenter sa
consommation de gaz il y a forte à
craindre que son prix s'envole et que le
marché mondial s'affole dans ce contexte
il est urgent de prolonger ses tarifs
réglementés pour ne pas plonger des
millions de Français dans la précarité
énergétique monsieur le ministre ma
question est simple sans créer un
nouveau chèque allez-vous reporter la
fin des tarifs réglementés de gaz prévu
le 30 juin 2023 sachant que depuis
octobre 2021 la Commission européenne
autorise les États à prendre des mesures
exceptionnelles pour la protection des
consommateurs je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est
communiste de l'Économie des Finances et
la souveraineté les prix ne vont pas
bondir pour le consommateur je vous
rassurer tout de suite ça fait deux ans
deux ans que la France plus que aucun
autre État européen protège le
consommateur français contre la flambée
des prix du gaz et la flambée des prix
de l'électricité ça s'appelle le
bouclier tarifaire tervégaz ou pas
tervégaz en juillet 2023 une fois
qu'effectivement le TRV aura été
supprimé il y aura la même protection le
même bouclier et le consommateur ne
paiera pas davantage la Premier ministre
indiqué le bouclier tarifaire est
maintenu jusqu'à la fin 2023 je rappelle
par ailleurs que sur 12 millions de
consommateurs de gaz dis sont déjà fait
le choix de sortir des TRV ce que je
sais bien que les mots entretiennent la
confusion mais autant sur l'électricité
nous sommes producteurs donc nous
pouvons réguler plafonner le tarif de
l'électricité c'est ce que nous ont avec
que les terres d'électricité pour les
très petites entreprises c'est ce que
nous faisons avec l'arène qui permet de
réduire en moyenne de 50% la facture
d'électricité des entreprises en France
ça nous pouvons le faire et nous
continuerons à le faire parce que
producteur d'électricité notamment de
l'électricité nucléaire mais nous ne
sommes pas producteurs de gaz donc nous
n'avons jamais n'avons pas les moyens de
plafonner le prix du gaz il a simplement
un prix de référence qui est fixé par la
Commission de régulation de l'énergie ce
prix de référence sera maintenu quoi
qu'il arrive sur les prix du gaz au-delà
de juin 2023 et je le redis la
protection tarifaire elle elle sera
garantie par le bouclier que nous avons
mis en place
monsieur sigoletti
merci monsieur le ministre mais dans un
environnement de plus en plus déréguré
le tarif réglementé de vente du gaz
reste une référence claire sur le marché
si le tarif réglementé disparaît il
manquera une référence à laquelle se
référer en cette période de trouble
merci
la parole est
notre collègue Stéphane Ravier
la Réunion administrative des
signataires de figurant sur la liste
d'aucun groupe vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse Madame la Ministre de la
censure de la culture pardon de la
culture
c'est assumé prendre c'est un si
méprendre madame la ministre le 9
février dernier vous avez clairement
menacé de ne pas renouveler les
fréquences de chaîne d'information
privée depuis les studios de média
public ces propos choquants représentent
une atteinte à l'indépendance de l'arcom
chargé de réguler la communication
audiovisuelle une atteinte au pluralisme
portée notamment par le travail des
équipes de C8 et cnews suivi par plus de
11 millions de téléspectateurs
quotidiennement une menace faite à la
liberté d'expression au débat
démocratique madame le ministre si vos
propos portent les valeurs de la
République ce sont celles d'une
république soviétique ou d'une
république bananière dois-je vous
rappeler que nous sommes ici à Paris et
pas à Pyongyang
votre atteinte à la liberté d'expression
au débat démocratique est aggravé par un
deux poids de mesure car samedi encore
la chaîne publique France 2 incapable
des gardes pour les élus d'opposition
accueillis en vedette un tueur en série
sans réaction de la reconni de votre
part vous avez une conception une
application très sélective du rappel du
cadre de la loi C8 collectionne elle
près de 6 millions 700 000 euros
d'amende depuis six ans pour 10 ans le
non respect de l'idéologie dominante
mais mon a inter Man et Françoise
Laborde toutes deux anciens membres du
CSA aujourd'hui Arcom n'ont pas manqué
de dénoncer votre insupportable pression
l'essence même de leur com et devrait
être sa totale indépendance vis-à-vis du
pouvoir politique en appelant leur
commun agir vous avez déjà et vous êtes
déjà dans l'ingérence et la pression la
vérité c'est qu'en 2025 nous serons en
deux ans de l'élection présidentielle et
que vous ne supportez plus que
l'opposition puisse s'exprimer sur une
chaîne qui pourtant fait preuve elle
de véritable pluralité en évitant toutes
les opinions toutes les opinions à
s'exprimer alors madame le ministre
alors que le renouvellement des
fréquences de la TNT a lieu en 2025
plutôt que de bravades ou de
fanfaronnade au conclure quel garantie
pouvez-vous nous apporter pour assurer
le plus réalisme la liberté de
l'information et du débat dans
l'audiovisuel français pour vous
répondre la parole est à madame la
ministre de la Culture madame Abdul
Mellac
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur sénateur ravier on
termine en beauté la première fois que
je vous avais entendu prononcé mon nom
vous aviez défini ma fonction communiste
de la déculture je vois qu'on monte d'un
cran je vous remercie pour cette
considération
alors
à chaque fois je rappelle le cadre de la
loi mais ce que j'entends dans ce que
vous venez de dire c'est que vous
contestez au fond les obligations qui
sont posées dans la loi de 86 vous les
contestez visiblement Vous contestez le
fait qu'il faille respecter la dignité
des personnes dans les chaînes de la TNT
qui bénéficient de fréquence gratuite
Vous contestez le fait que on ne peut
pas insulter par exemple un
parlementaire Vous contestez le fait
qu'on ne peut pas
inciter à la haine puisque l'arcom avait
en toute indépendance c'est une décision
de l'art comme
rendu cette décision qui sanctionnait
une des chaînes que vous mentionnez pour
des propos qui en gros
insulter les mineurs étrangers en les
traitant tous de violeurs d'agresseurs
et d'assassins donc vous contestez
finalement la loi si je comprends bien
vous contester le cadre de la loi alors
que je suis ici face à des législateurs
qui sont attachés à cette loi cette loi
qui est le fondement de notre démocratie
le fondement de ce qui fait le
pluralisme l'indépendance de
l'information dans notre pays et à
laquelle je suis viscéralement attachée
c'est ça la conclusion et en plus venant
de vous
je suis d'autant plus étonnée que vous
défendiez aujourd'hui de la liberté de
la presse quand on sait il y a pas si
longtemps que le candidat que vous
défendiez à l'élection présidentielle
faisait huer les journalistes dans ces
meetings et que certains se sont même
fait agresser à ces meetings donc on a
vraiment pas de leçon à recevoir de
votre part respectons la loi rappelons
la loi rien que la loi merci madame la
ministre
les questions gouvernement nos
prochaines questions auront lieu le
mercredi 1er mars à 15 heures
la science va être suspendue elle sera
reprise à 16h30 pour l'examen
d'approvision de loi visant à sécuriser
l'approvisionnement des Français en
produits de grandes consommations la
séance est suspendue merci